monte à quelque chose
allez
je vais aller devant tu vas les devants
obligé je pense de décembre c'est le
cadre de
mary final cela fait un bout de temps
non si vous savez ce que tu es un
commentaire
à lessard et du scooter
on voit ça
et c'est moi qui les lancers en plus ce
serait pour les deux hommes
j'ai pas réussi à le relever un petit
peu trop loin moment
de tout ce que toi
quentin
au
stand de moto
alors
je pense qu'on est sur un autre cadre de
twitter
un déambulateur ou crotty net aux as
l'air bien
trop gros non
ya pas que ça il ya une trottinette et
un cadre aussi
non il est d'éviter
assez pour enfants
c'est pire
tout ça
autant reconstituer l'accident alors
exactement
je suis très loin derrière regarde ça
c'est des traces de l'accident dans ce
cas les quatre mais cela remettre comme
ça en attendant pour que tu puisses
quand même aller à l'école avec
ya plein de trucs juste devant les
jeunes j'ai un truc et du coup ça me
bloque dans les rochers
des clous le début c'est moi qui les
sols
ouais ouais je filme bien sûr alors y
est
déjà mais quand tu as fait toujours tout
[Musique]
les césar sont pas le porter non
moi je
fais à nu mais là c'est vraiment
l'endroit parfait je sais que ces propos
étaient tout à l'heure c'est ça ton lit
du coup il n'a pas présenté mais
aujourd'hui on est en vidéo avec la
holding qui est aussi caméraman atteint
hier qu'on attend
ouais et l'autre voisine et en
initiation pêche éléments
alors tout amusé les résidences c'est
dégueulasse
à l'est sud est y allé à l'eau
oh eun sun
[Musique]
c'est tout ça va finir par
laisser à nettoyer
enlevé en vrille les tympans l'action
nokia
un soutien plus fort
comme à troyes va quoi
on allait ouvert les volets clos et pas
de goûter
là il ya quelque chose
à plein de trucs a regardées du câble la
mauvaise
mon père encore terme au top
voilà
ça va
j'ai pu l'entendre
ajoutez fin
aux
donc là il ya un arbre de voiture
embrassades
des panneaux sont
sympas
et l'âme entretiennent
il a fait un pot d'échappement des
mobylettes
avec sa casquette qui dépasse de beckett
qui les passe de la casquette joue
chaque fois je la mets dans ma tête elle
reporte tout le temps de regarder vous
abandonnez
porte un peu plus
d'ajouter la casquette de jpp cheveux
clément
oui c'est pas facile à vélo des raisons
historiques
[Musique]
au computer
la bullet time
ça promet
tout comme en miettes
moi je prends la cantine est est
peut-être le vélo à 12 heures
[Musique]
là tu vois que quelques semaines ouais
voilà j'ai attrapé michael tiemann
encore des bouts de l'eau c'est parti
pour confectionner cette petite bio
c'était sympa aussi baigner mais voilà
le chien aboie juste pour la conclusion
ne parlera pas par contre c'est
vraiment pas mal de vélo découpé par ici
ouais ici des scooters des vélos la 30e'
neige glacée très vieux alors que le
spot là bas on était quand même plus
propre du réseau avec une foi qui doit
être plutôt sympa et surtout un transat
com a nettoyé et on va taper no mercy
est là dessus tout l'été